[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es eine weitere Folge von
„Nachgemacht – Original trifft Sally“
- und zwar ein Rezeptwunsch von…
MAX: Max. [Applaus]
SALLY: … von Max. [Lacht]
Max hat eine Torte mitgebracht. [Max stimmt zu]
Was verbindet dich mit dieser Torte?
MAX: Die kauft meine Oma immer gerne.
Also sie geht immer einkaufen und kauft diese Torte.
Ich muss sagen, am Anfang war ich eher skeptisch,
weil ich nicht so der Fertigtorten-Typ bin.
Dann hat sie sie einmal ausgepackt
und ich wollte sie ab sofort dann immer essen.
SALLY: Gibt es sie dann so zum Sonntagskaffeeklatsch? [Max bejaht]
Oder auch unter der Woche?
MAX: Eigentlich kauft sie die Torte immer.
Immer, wenn sie einkaufen ist, nimmt sie sie mit.
Sie hat dann auch manchmal 2 oder 3 drin.
SALLY: Also immer etwas da, wenn dann Gäste kommen. [Max stimmt zu]
Ich muss auch sagen, ich habe auch so eine Fertigtortenvergangenheit.
Wir hatten eine Nachbarin – die Frau Imscheid.
Bei ihr war es auch so,
dass sie uns immer zu Kaffee und Kuchen eingeladen hat.
Sie hat auch selbst nie gebacken.
Daher gab es ganz oft Coppenrath & Wiese, eben Fertigtorten.
Für mich war es schon immer ein Highlight in der Kindheit,
weil es bei Mama nie Fertigkuchen gab.
Sie hat immer nur selbst gebacken
und dann immer Marmor- oder Zitronenkuchen.
Dann war es schon immer ein Highlight, so eine Torte zu essen.
MAX: Dann war es immer so ein bisschen verboten,
weil man es zu Hause nicht durfte. [Sally stimmt zu]
Dann hat die Oma das gehabt und dann war es so ein Highlight.
SALLY: Bei uns auch.
Bei Frau Imscheid gab es dann auch immer Filterkaffe.
Dann kam ich zu ihr in die Wohnung und es hat schon so gerochen.
Ach, das war immer schön.
Okay. Aber heute gibt es bei uns keine Fertigtorte,
sondern „Nachgemacht – Original trifft Sally“.
Bedeutet: Ich mache für euch die Torte nach.
Wie ich immer sage: Bei diesem Format geht es nicht darum,
dass ich eine Torte günstiger, besser oder egal wie zubereite.
Es geht einfach darum, etwas Fertiges nachzumachen
und euch zu zeigen, wie man so eine Torte selbst backen kann,
weil ich nie Konkurrenz zum eigentlich Produkt herstellen möchte,
denn so eine Fertigtorte hat natürlich auch ihre Daseinsberechtigung,
wenn man einfach einmal keine Zeit hat, den Geschmack schon mag
oder schon eine eingefahrene Tradition hat.
MAX: Mit der Oma.
SALLY: Mit der Oma. Ich habe schon auf dem Bild gesehen.
Das sieht man ganz gut: Sie hat einen Mürbeteigboden,
also einen Keksboden, einen Schokobiskuit, Bananen und Sahne drin.
Jetzt gucken wir erst einmal – so.
Es sieht original aus wie auf dem Bild.
Ich vergleiche das nämlich immer, weil manche Produkte nicht so sind,
aber diese sieht original aus wie hier. Schön!
MAX: Da habe ich noch nicht darauf geachtet. Ich esse immer bloß.
SALLY: Manche Schokoriegel packen wir aus
und dann sehen sie ganz anders aus.
Also: Mürbeteigboden, Biskuit, Bananen und dann gucken wir einmal
- Stracciatella-Sahne, hier noch Bröselchen
und Schokosplitter obendrauf.
Dann würde ich sagen,
ich backe jetzt und du darfst später zum Probieren kommen.
MAX: Supi! [Karate-Soundeffekte]
SALLY: Dann gibt es jetzt also den Mürbeteig.
Da nutze ich einfach mein 1-2-3 Grundrezept.
Die Torte lasse ich hier noch schön auftauen,
denn später wollen wir natürlich beide gleichwertig probieren.
Dann darf sie natürlich nicht gefroren sein.
Für den Mürbeteig nehme ich 70 g Zucker, 140 g kalte Butter,
210 g Mehl, etwas Vanilleextrakt und Salz.
Den Mürbeteig könnt ihr jetzt entweder in der Küchenmaschine,
mit einem Handrührgerät oder auch mit einem Mixer
mit Mixmessern zubereiten – das geht auch ganz gut.
Mürbeteig hieß früher auch Hackteig,
weil man ihn mit einem Messer zerhackt hat.
Wichtig ist einfach, dass die Zutaten kalt sind.
Wie gesagt, ihr könnt ihn auch so ganz klassisch zubereiten.
Es ist nur ganz wichtig, dass die Zutaten kalt sind
und auch kalt bleiben, d.h. gar nicht so lange mit den Händen kneten.
Falls ihr keine Maschine und kein Handrührgerät habt,
dann am besten entweder mit einer Teigkarte zubereiten
oder mit einem Messer auf einem Holzbrett.
D.h., man zerhackt dann die ganzen Zutaten.
So bleibt die Butter kalt und der Teig wird schön mürbe.
Oder, wenn ihr habt, könnt ihr auch einen Teigzerhacker nehmen.
Damit geht es ein bisschen schneller,
weil man sozusagen 4 Messer hat und das Ganze eben so zerhacken kann.
Dann werde ich ganz am Ende die Zutaten
so ein bisschen mit den Händen zusammenkneten.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr dann merkt, jetzt ist der Teig so weit,
einfach mit den Händen kurz zusammenfügen,
zu einer schönen glatten Kugel.
[Musik]
Dann kommt der Teig in den Kühlschrank,
am besten auf einem Teller flachdrücken.
So kann er schneller abkühlen. Dann dauert das Ganze etwa 30 Min.
Schön abdecken und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon einmal den Ofen vorheizen und den Biskuit backen
und dann im Anschluss direkt den Mürbeteig weiterverarbeiten.
[Musik und Uhr]
Für den Biskuit nehme ich 4 Eier, etwas Vanilleextrakt und Salz,
100 g Zucker, 70 g Mehl und 30 g Kakao.
Hier beim Biskuit achtet ihr jetzt am besten darauf,
dass die Eier Zimmerwarm sind.
So lassen sie sich nämlich besser aufschlagen.
Das sind einfach Basics, die man sich merken kann.
Also eigentlich bei Rührteig und Biskuitteig
die Zutaten eher zimmerwarm und bei Mürbeteig eher kalt.
Jetzt gebe ich hier die Eier mit Salz, Vanilleextrakt und Zucker
in die Rührschüssel. Ein Handrührgerät geht natürlich auch.
Das Ganze wird ca. 5-10 Min. schön weißschaumig aufgeschlagen.
[Musik]
So sieht die Masse perfekt aus. Also fast schon steif wie Eisschnee.
Dann braucht man auch wirklich kein Backpulver zu benutzen.
Dann geht ein Biskuit wunderbar ohne Backpulver auf.
Dann Mehl und Kakao dazu sieben, vorsichtig unterheben
und anschließend in die Backform einfüllen.
Die habe ich jetzt auf 24 cm Durchmesser gestellt.
Den Mürbeteig backe ich gleich auf 26 cm,
denn auch bei Originaltorte ist Biskuit ein bisschen kleiner
als der Mürbeteig. Daher mache ich das jetzt so.
Ansonsten könnt ihr es aber auch gern gleichgroß zubereiten.
Also ich glaube, das hat jetzt eher optische als praktische Gründe.
Von daher macht es so, wie es für euch am besten passt.
Jetzt den Biskuit hier rein, direkt schön verteilen
und sofort im heißen Ofen backen.
Dann kann ich mich schon einmal um den Mürbeteig kümmern.
[Musik]
Jetzt könnt ihr den kalten Teig nehmen.
Man kann sich übrigens Mürbeteig auch auf Vorrat herstellen
und ihn immer im Gefrierfach lagern.
Dann habt ihr immer etwas parat, wenn ihr einmal Mürbeteig braucht.
[Musik]
Kurz durchkneten und dann auf die Stärke von etwa 3 mm ausrollen.
Diesen rolle ich jetzt auf eine Größe von 26 cm aus.
[Musik]
Jetzt stürze ich das Ganze vor dem Ausstechen auf meine Backfolie.
Ich nehme hier einen Tortenretter darunter.
Hmm, schaffe ich das so?
Schaffe ich es so? Ich schaffe es so! Tschuuu.
Aber ich schaffe es nur mit Geräusch.
Jetzt praktisch 26 cm – habe ich schon eingestellt.
Einmal ausstechen und das Drumherum wegnehmen.
Aus dem übrigen Teig könnt ihr gern noch leckere Kekse backen
oder ihn, wie gesagt, einfrieren.
Was ich jetzt noch machen werde,
damit der Teig beim Backen nicht hochgeht und er keine Bläschen wirft:
Einfach mit einer Gabel oder einer Teigkarte einstechen.
[Musik]
Da der Ofen jetzt noch mit dem Biskuit belegt ist,
kommt er jetzt noch einmal in den Kühlschrank;
wenn ihr Platz habt, sogar gern in den Gefrierschrank,
damit der Teig richtig schön kalt und dann heiß gebacken werden kann.
In der Zeit kann ich aufräumen
und dann geht es eigentlich wieder Schlag auf Schlag weiter,
denn ihr könnt immer in der Zwischenzeit
Zeit sparen und schön aufräumen.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Biskuit und Mürbeteig sind jetzt abgekühlt.
Jetzt geht es an die Stracciatella-Creme.
Ich weiß jetzt natürlich nicht, ob da Quark oder…
Doch, natürlich weiß ich es: Auf der Verpackung stand kein Quark.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach nur eine Sahnecreme
mit Schokoladenstücken.
Ich mache das Ganze aber auf Sally-Art,
deswegen mit Quark und Mascarpone und zeige euch die Zutaten.
Für die Creme verwende ich 250 g Mascarpone, 80 g Puderzucker,
250 g Quark, Vanilleextrakt und Zitronensaft, 400 g Sahne,
etwas San-apart zum Steifschlagen, 100 g Schokoladenraspeln,
etwas Marmelade und reife Bananen.
Im Prinzip ist es wie eine ganz normale Quark-Mascarpone-Sahnecreme.
Erst einmal den Mascarpone mit Puderzucker verrühren.
Hier jetzt darauf achten, dass alle Zutaten kalt sind,
vor allem die Sahne, der Quark und die Mascarpone – DER Mascarpone.
Es ist mir aber egal,
auch wenn ich den Artikel der Mascarpone falsch sage.
Es ist bei mir im Hirn eingebrannt: DIE Mascarpone und nicht DER.
Deswegen korrigiere ich mich auch jetzt ab sofort nicht mehr,
außer ich denke daran.
Das ist eine Frechheit, dass es DER Mascarpone heißt.
Das ist einfach eine Frechheit.
Klar, es ist DER Frischkäse, aber trotzdem! DIE passt besser.
Es heißt ja auch DAS Mädchen, obwohl es weiblich ist.
DIE Frau, DAS Mädchen – was soll denn das?
DER Mann, DER Junge – DIE Frau, DAS Mädchen.
Das war doch keine Gender-Debatte. Also geht’s noch?! [Lacht]
Also geht’s noch? Wirklich jetzt mal? [Lacht]
Vanilleextrakt dazu, ein bisschen Zitronensaft.
Dann die Zutaten kurz schon einmal verrühren.
[Handrührgerät]
Die Sahne langsam dazu gießen
und dann einfach mit San-apart steifschlagen.
[Musik]
Die Schokostückchen dann nur noch unterheben.
Ich lasse jetzt ein paar übrig, die dann noch darauf kommen.
Eigentlich nicht – nein, die kommen ganz mit rein,
denn obendrauf mache ich Schokoröllchen.
Ja, bei Coppenrath sind nämlich auch schöne Röllchen drauf.
Diese kommen aber hier rein.
[Musik]
Die Sahnecreme habe ich kurz in den Kühlschrank gestellt.
Ich habe jetzt hier den Keksboden,
den ich auf einen Tortenretter ziehe.
Der sieht auch wirklich, muss ich einmal zeigen, hervorragend aus.
Richtig schön!
Dann löse ich den Biskuit heraus.
Den hatte ich eben noch im Kühlschrank nach dem Abkühlen,
damit er sich besser schneiden lässt.
Hier die Backfolie lösen.
Ich habe euch den Tipp mit der Backfolie, glaube ich,
schon öfter gegeben: Wenn sie noch ein paar Rückstände hat,
einfach mit einer Teigkarte ohne Palette die Brösel abziehen.
Dann habt ihr die Reste beim Abwaschen nicht
an eurem Küchenschwamm hängen und es ist ein bisschen einfacher.
Die nehme ich gleich noch, denn ich brauche sowieso Crumble obendrauf.
Also nicht wegschmeißen, sondern verwerten.
So ein schöner Biskuit!
Da schneide ich jetzt hier oben einfach ein bisschen weg,
damit ich es zerbröseln kann.
Hier einfach mit der Tortensäge einen ganz kleinen Deckel.
Das macht man normalerweise,
wenn man den Tortenboden schön gerade haben möchte,
aber der backt immer schön gerade,
aber ich will es ja trotzdem originalgetreu zur Fertigtorte.
Daher machen wir das so.
So ein bisschen, muss ich sagen,
erinnert mich die Torte an eine Maulwurftorte.
Maulwurftorte oder Maulwurfkuchen? Kuchen? Torte?
Also eigentlich ist es eine Torte, aber man sagt Kuchen dazu.
[Musik]
Ich weiß jetzt nicht,
ob im Original Marmelade auf dem Mürbeteigboden ist, aber ich finde,
wenn der Mürbeteig mit dem Biskuit und Marmelade verbunden wird,
dann ist es hervorragend. Deswegen mache ich das so.
Es hält dann auch besser
und bringt noch einmal etwas Fruchtiges mit rein.
Ich habe hier einfach eine Aprikosenmarmelade, ein Fruchtaufstrich,
mit 85 g Früchten pro 100 g.
Da achte ich, ehrlich gesagt, ganz gerne darauf,
denn dann ist es umso fruchtiger und nicht so süß.
[Musik]
Dann legt ihr den Biskuit hier drauf – schön mittig.
Ich habe hier die reifen Bananen.
Beim Maulwurfkuchen werden sie hingelegt.
Bei dieser Torte werden sie aufgestellt.
Dann stellen wir sie auch auf.
[Musik]
Ich schneide die Bananen jetzt gleichmäßig 2 cm dick ab.
Dann hier schön aufstellen. Am besten nicht ganz bis zum Rand,
sondern ein bisschen Rand lassen.
[Musik]
Dann fülle ich die Masse in einen Spritzbeutel
mit einer großen Lochtülle ein.
[Musik]
Mir fällt gerade ein,
ich habe einmal eine Banana Split Biskuitrolle zubereitet.
Das war, glaube ich, im ersten Jahr, als ich angefangen hatte.
Es muss 2012 oder 2013 gewesen sein.
Jetzt gebe ich hier den Tortenring wieder außenherum.
Ich habe es jetzt hier im Spritzbeutel drin,
damit ich hier unten noch schön den Rand auffüllen kann.
Ihr könnt es aber auch ohne Spritzbeutel machen.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Ich habe jetzt leider auch noch die alten Spritzbeutel,
die ein bisschen kleiner sind, fällt mir jetzt wieder ein,
denn ich habe mich schon an die großen und mit Grip gewöhnt,
aber es ist okay. Die benutze ich jetzt hier noch.
Jetzt einfach rundherum hineinspritzen und dann wirklich so weit,
bis die Bananen überdeckt sind.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier die Lücken dazwischen noch ausfüllen.
Dann die Creme ein bisschen glattstreichen
[Musik]
und ruhig auch so ein bisschen die Creme sozusagen
von oben nach unten in die Bananenlücken hineindrücken.
Ich habe die Bananen doch ein bisschen größer als 2 cm geschnitten.
Deswegen reicht mir die Creme auch nicht mehr aus,
um die Tupfen zu machen.
Ich würde aber im Rezept das Ganze so belassen, denn ich denke,
das Verhältnis von Creme zur Torte, Kuchen und Banane ist ganz gut.
Ich muss mir jetzt allerdings noch einmal ein bisschen Creme anrühren,
damit ich noch die Tupfen machen kann,
aber ich denke, für euch passt es.
Wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt die Optik glatt,
dann könnt ihr es natürlich auch so lassen.
Aber da es ja „Original trifft Sally“ heißt,
muss ich natürlich auch diese kleinen Hubbels zubereiten.
Dafür mache ich noch einmal eine Creme
und spritze das Ganze dann obendrauf.
Dann ist die Torte auch schon gleich fertig!
So lange stelle ich sie aber kühl.
[Musik]
Also ich habe jetzt noch einmal die halbe Portion der Creme
zusätzlich zubereitet. Um diese Optik herzustellen,
mache ich Sahnetupfer mit dieser großen Lochtülle.
Einfach komplett und auf jeden Fall eine große Lochtülle nehmen,
denn ihr habt ja diese Schokosplitter.
Ansonsten verstopfen sie die Tülle.
[Musik]
Aww, jetzt habe ich so einen schönen Schmetterling gebaut.
Jetzt zerstöre ich ihn, denn…
[Sally und Josh lachen]
denn jetzt kommen die Kuchenbrösel.
Es ist immer schwierig, einen Kuchen zu zerbröseln, der saftig ist.
Aber wisst ihr, wie ihr das machen könnt?
Wenn der Ofen noch warm ist, dann stellt ihr einfach das Backpapier
bzw. die Backfolie in den Ofen und trocknet es noch einmal kurz an.
Dann habt ihr nämlich schöne Bröselchen
und diese kommen dann hier drauf.
[Musik]
Und zum Abschluss noch Schokoladenröllchen.
Die mache ich jetzt hier mit einem Sparschäler
und einem Stück Schokolade.
Dann kommt die Torte insgesamt für mind. 2 Stunden in den Kühlschrank
und kann dann herausgelöst und probiert werden.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Jetzt kommt die Verkostung, lieber Max. Ich bin gespannt darauf,
wie dir meine Coppenrath & Wiese Banana Split Torte schmeckt.
MAX: Ich bin auch gespannt.
SALLY: Ehm, ich habe mit den Bananen vielleicht übertrieben,
aber ich finde, das ist eine Banana Split Torte
und auf dem Bild sind die Bananenstückchen auch größer.
Hier sind es doch mehr Scheiben, muss ich zugeben.
Deswegen hat ja auch meine Creme nicht ausgereicht,
aber komm! Eine Torte braucht Creme.
MAX: Aber sieht gut aus!
SALLY: Du darfst gern probieren. Es sind frische Gabeln.
MAX: Alles klar. Soll ich hier eine ganze Banane mitnehmen?
SALLY: Wie du möchtest.
Ich probiere auch mal eine Gabel voll.
MAX: Mmh!
SALLY: Mmh!
MAX: Sorry Oma, aber das ist besser.
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Ich glaube, das verkraftet die Oma. [Max stimmt zu]
Wie heißt denn deine Oma?
MAX: Renate, die Granate.
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Liebe Oma Renate, der Max bringt dir bestimmt einmal
ein Stück selbstgebackene Banana Split Torte mit.
MAX: Ich versuche mal, sie einmal selbst zu machen.
SALLY: Ja, oder?
Ich probiere sie.
Ich gebe Oma Renate recht. Also, es ist schon eine gute Torte,
aber ich bin natürlich der Fan von selbstgemacht.
Daher dürft ihr gern das Rezept ausprobieren.
Wer sagt, nein, ich mach es wie Oma Renate, dann macht es wie sie.
MAX: Aber diese ist größer.
SALLY: Aber diese ist größer. Da hat man mehr davon. Das stimmt.
Ich hätte tatsächlich die Torte vielleicht direkt
nebendran lassen sollen, so im direkten Vergleich, aber gut.
Ich finde – komm…
Es kann nie zu viel Creme, es können nie zu viele Bananen sein.
Von daher bin ich schon Fan von der großen Torte.
Da kommt auch gerade Siamak. Siamak, komm rein!
Wo wir von großen Torten sprechen,
kommt natürlich der Tortenspezialist Siamak.
[Beide lachen]
Guck mal, Banana Split Torte von Coppenrath & Wiese.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, was ist original, was ist Fälschung,
aber das steht ja drunter.
Komm, Siamak! Hier, gönn dir!
[Lacht] Wenn ich schon zufällig da bin.
Mit Keksboden! Ich liebe Torten mit Keksboden.
Ich glaube, das hatte in der Konditorei eher praktische Gründe,
dass man die Torten mit dem knusprigen Boden
auch bewegen und wegstellen kann,
aber ich finde es darunter einfach lecker.
Gut?
MAX: Gut, oder?
SIAMAK: Das ist ein Maulwurfkuchen.
SALLY: Ja! Wie so eine Maulwurftorte.
SIAMAK: Ist da ein bisschen Zitrone drin?
SALLY: Ja, weil ich es mag, wenn in der Sahne Zitrone ist.
SIAMAK: Ist fruchtiger.
MAX: Das habe ich nicht herausgeschmeckt.
SALLY: Siehst du? Der Siamak… Das lernst du noch.
SIAMAK: Erfahrung!
SALLY: Das lernst du noch. Er hat 4 Jahre Vorsprung.
[Alle lachen]
SIAMAK: Das lernst du noch. Dein Bauch lernt es auch noch.
SALLY: Also, falls ihr die Torte nachbacken wollt,
das Rezept gibt es auf Sallys-Blog.de oder in meiner App.
Ihr könnt sie gern groß zubereiten
oder in der App für eine kleinere Torte auch umrechnen lassen.
Ich bin aber für die große Torte, oder Siamak?
SIAMAK: [Stimmt zu] Da ist mehr Butter und Sahne drin.
[Sallys Handy klingelt]
SALLY: Viel Spaß beim Nachmachen. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss!
MAX: Tschüss!
SALLY: Das ist mein Wecker. Ich muss Ela zum Tanzen bringen.
[Max lacht]
SIAMAK: Ich wollte eigentlich nur den Staubsauger holen.
SALLY: Ach so. Er wollte den Staubsauger holen,
aber hat aus Versehen ein Tortenstück mitgenommen.
SIAMAK: Ich wollte eigentlich abnehmen
und jetzt habe ich wieder zugenommen.
[Sally lacht]
[Musik]